what'd you have for breakfast today
coffee with what sweetened condensed
milk is that better than it's the best
you should try it why because it adds a
little sweetness it makes your coffee
extra creamy so no solid food today for
you not yet besides your lunch of course
and now the game begins you know people
who haven't eaten my lunch say they ate
my lunch people who have eaten my lunch
say they ate my lunch just to throw me
off what's your favorite sandwich
grilled cheese warm preferably cold
grilled cheese doesn't quite have the
same milk I was going to talk about
consistency you said melt Factor yeah
yeah there's a creaminess to grilled
cheese do you you like a certain mouth
feel yeah at least so far in in your
comfort food